ce n'est plus une vue de l'esprit notre
climat continue de se modifier et les
phénomènes météorologiques sont de plus
en plus extrêmes pour environnement
canada
l'événement le plus marquant a été la
saison des feux de forêt la plus longue
et la plus destructrice en colombie
britannique
quand on regarde l'étendue la durée le
nombre de personnes qui ont un qui ont
dû quitter leur maison c'est près de
50000 personnes qui ont dû quitter leur
maison pour plusieurs semaines
c'est pour ces raisons là principalement
que les feux de forêt encore d'années
que ça retrouve au numéro un vient
ensuite la sécheresse dans l'ouest
et bien sûr les inondations printanières
au québec et en ontario
ça a vraiment été une combinaison de
deux facteurs principalement l'hiver
2010 est a été un hiver avec un petit
peu plus dommage qu'à l'habitude mais là
une des grandes raisons des inondations
a été le mois de mars qui était très
froid donc la forme de sept nageurs
étaient retardés et quand on est arrivé
à la mi avril début mai on a eu des
pluies très importante tout le pays a
été affectée il n'y a pas eu d'été au
centre du canada au québec il s'est
véritablement installée en septembre
c'est un fait un peu cocasse que le 22
septembre
ça a été la journée ou en ennemi le
premier avertissement de chaleur au
québec
et c'était en même temps le début de
l'automne et le nouveau brunswick a
connu cette tempête de verglas mémorable
plus question de fermer les yeux sur les
changements climatiques dus au
réchauffement de la température depuis
au moins 20 ans les changements
climatiques vont faire que les épisodes
vont être non seulement plus violent
mais parfois bons sets serrés sur une
plus longue période
les scientifiques sont formels il faut
maintenant passer de la parole aux actes
afin de ralentir le réchauffement
climatique et ainsi minimiser les dégâts
s'il n'est pas trop tard ici catherine
kovacs radio canada montréal